evidence is emerging of systematic
killings of civilians by russian forces
in the district of makariv 45 miles east
of kiev officials say more than 130
bodies have already been found
among them a 62 year old shot in the
head with the russian army now gone the
process of collecting and documenting
those killed has begun
last week 20 bodies were found in the
heavily bombarded town of makarov about
an hour west of kiev the discovery came
after ukrainian authorities reclaimed
control of towns and villages on the
outskirts of the capital including
butcher and borodianka
from there
in makariv
sky's security and defense editor
deborah haynes has this report a warning
it does contain some distressing images
armed with a list of locations and a
weapon the policemen set off
they work in a small town outside kiev a
peaceful place until the war came now
rather than petty crime their mission is
picking up bodies
and it's relentless
[Music]
[Applause]
this one was a man
they say he was a civilian but don't
know his name
the remains have burnt beyond
recognition
carefully they zip him up and move on
the lead police officer says russian
troops attacked the town of makarev and
seized several surrounding villages in
this would have been russian army
when
shoot on our city
ukrainian forces finally pushed them
back last week
evidence of the retreat met with glee
humor a good shield when dealing with
the horror russia's forces left behind
this one team has collected more than 20
bodies in the past three days
one
month on our territory
gold wall
i see
how my friend explo
after this i
don't have feels about
about when when i found by this
they pull up outside the home of yuri
vasukin in the nearby village of
vishagrad
a pensioner he was at home alone when
russian soldiers paid a visit in early
march
they apparently beat the 62 year old
then shot him in the head
his remains eventually buried in the
back garden
now finally retrieved for examination
and a proper burial
his son is still in shock
why was he killed
on the 3rd of march he called his dad
pictured here but now wonders whether it
was really him because his voice sounded
strange it's what happened to your
father a war crime
yes
the next door neighbor was also killed
a retired police sergeant a colleague
russian troops seem to have gone house
to house challenging residents and at
times shooting them and now we've got
the police literally following their
trail going from one house to the next
digging up bodies in the back garden
nine miles away is the hamlet of
andreyevka
this is where the mayor's cousin vitaly
is buried after being executed seemingly
for what he had on his mobile phones the
neighbor
[Music]
um
back with the police they load up their
van it smells of death and there are
three more bodies to collect
time to go
debra haynes sky news makarev